hi everyone thanks for joining our
virtual chat today I were pleased to be
able to connect with you I literally
during this activity of this CVR 2020
we're going to bring your thoughts on
computer vision we're going to talk
about the history we're going to talk
about the current state and some what
about where it's headed next
so this video is pre-recorded so we're
not going to take any questions live
however I encourage you to visit our
serial page on Amazon that science a to
reach out to our recruiting team to
connect with us about opportunities at
Ana as I mentioned this discussion is
inspired by our focus on cvpr
which is held this week virtually due to
our travel restriction and health
concerns stemming from zhirkova 19
pandemic our thoughts are with all those
affected and we hope that everybody
watching is staying safe with that I'm
pleased to welcome my colleagues and
professor Larry Davis professor Pietro
Perona who leaders in the field of
computer vision research who are going
to be joining me for what hopefully is
going to be an informative and inspiring
discussion especially for students who
are considering your career related to
computer vision so let's take a few
minutes introduce ourselves let's start
with Larry alright thanks Gerard right
so I've been with Amazon since late 2018
I joined really right after Thanksgiving
and I'm in a group called soft wines
that's the organization in Amazon that
sells clothing online so since I've
arrived so husband softphones has been
building up a large science organization
in collaboration with other groups in
Amazon around the world so we have
scientists in Europe it's Germany Spain
the UK India Israel and Australia
working on problems related to clothing
right so the Sun never sets on soap on
science our goal is to help customers
find clothes
that it's their styles their shapes and
their budget and to make shopping more
of a fun experience in fact later I'll
talk and detail about one of the
projects which is described in our cvpr
paper that we worked on to try and help
customers shop for clothing before
joining Amazon I was at University of
Maryland in the computer science
department I was a faculty member there
in fact I still it's the lamb for about
40 years I'm currently on leap from that
position Marilyn has a large and vibrant
computer vision laboratory in fact the
lab celebrated its fiftieth anniversary
just a few years ago and one of the
areas I worked on with a couple of my
remarkable students the past several
years was fashion image analysis and I
came to Amazon to translate some of that
academic research into products that
help customers shop great thank you Mary
so I'm sure our video me I'm a vice
president and distinguished scientist I
came to Amazon in to say June 2014 and
my role is pretty much to drive the tech
that goes into our Amazon guru and just
walk out technology hey so what did I
come to to Amazon well I was a very
happy professor at the University of
Southern California in LA where I spent
my entire career 40 years I'm still am
I'm now emeritus professor but I went
from student to Professor to chair of
the C's department I was teaching AI
computer vision as conducting research
with my PhD student coming to Amazon to
work on Amazon roll and just work out
technology was this very unique
opportunity to put in practice
everything that had been teaching and
publishing throughout my career making
computer vision work in a retail
environment to create the shopping
experience where customer can just
walking into an Amazon book store grab
what they want and just walked out no
lines no checkout well that was an
opportunity that was very hard to resist
a
one of the team that that helps bring
Amazon the customer obsession to life
and create that experience that customer
actually love is a wonderful reward
Pietro I don't have an ID lovey and
hello everyone who's listening to us
mm-hmm I would love to be there in
person but of course we cannot so if my
story is similar I'd been a professor at
Cal Tech for about thirty years right
now always working in computer vision
and you must know I mean it's difficult
to believe now that until five years ago
not much worked in computer vision so we
were full of ideas most brilliant ideas
and but none would work very well and
you know my thesis I worked on edge
detection which is I feel that nowadays
is not almost not existent and I always
hoped that we would be able to reproduce
the ability of a human visual system one
day and in machines but the hope
remained at home for a long time and now
in the last five years things have
started to work and as any engineer I
take enormous pride in seeing that my
field can contribute to society to
industry to entertainment mm-hmm and so
like many people like Jarrar and like
Larry I felt a little bit of an itch to
be out there and see the idea to come up
with in academia become reality in
services and products that people can
use so in my case I have been working
for about twenty years now on visual
categorization and part of that work has
been collecting and annotating large
data sets that can be used for training
machine vision systems and I started
some of eight years we developed for for
crowdsourcing annotations could now what
I did for primetime ready to be used by
other people in the field in computer
vision and in industry
and and they joined Amazon Web Services
to see if I could help make that happen
now you must know and in fact you know
that Amazon put out a funky little thing
which is called Amazon Mechanical Turk
in about 2005 2006 and people in
computer vision noticed that fight away
and use it immediately to scale up
tremendously the capability of
annotating large image datasets and
that's what Coulomb enabled us to put
together a few data collections like
Caltech 101 initially and then
eventually imagenet by AFA which
triggered the the deep network
revolution
so really Amazon is one of the key
contributors to the current wave of the
of AI through one as a Mechanical Turk
and and so when I came into Amazon I was
extremely impressed and they wanted to
help make it even better and so now we
have a new service called ground truth
which it was the the chief scientist
that helps people do it so even
professors like me now can can annotate
large datasets and I don't have to
implore my students to help me out for
doing that so I'm very proud of that
I have democratized code source in to
the point that professors can use it
anyway so that's what they do and I mean
generally involved in putting AI in the
cloud at Amazon Web Services I think of
ideas that can be put out for services
for computer vision I also help with
with speech and tax right now and so
hopefully all of you can try out things
because they're out in the cloud and
they can be used back to Sarah Thank You
Deirdre okay so great so so let's kick
this kick off this discussion by
starting with the origin of computer
vision research so at petrol
I think computer vision can be traced
back to this famous MIT summer project
in the mid-60s and in particular we can
look at Larry Roberts MIT PhD thesis
which was called the time machine
perception in 3-dimensional solids
but in fact this fascination with images
for image formation image interpretation
goes way back so kid Rowe can you talk
about this earlier works and relation to
also fields such as biology for example
yeah anyone can download Roberts thesis
1963 and so I would encourage all the
students here to them load this old old
piece of relic if you will and see how
people viewed computer vision at the
time it's very interesting and so as
Cheryl says you know humans have been
aware that we see for the longest time
like you know we can go blind if we
damage our eyes it's clear and hmm
however the question of so there are two
key questions that people weren't really
thinking about for a long time one is
realizing that vision is a complex broad
process so the image forms on the back
of our eye and we have little pixel like
structures photoreceptors and so our
input is a matrix of numbers which
doesn't contain any explicit information
about what we see and so there must be
some amazing process to convert
asthmatics of numbers into into meaning
into information about the world out
there and the second one is that this
piece of information the image is not
terribly informative there is a lot of
information we don't have access to and
there is a lot of ambiguity so I think
that people became aware of this in
beginning of being aware of this in the
Renaissance when painters discovered
perspective because they started
thinking that instead of representing
images as concepts they wanted to
represent the real world out there and
so this is the beginning of humanism and
so people are not interested in a longer
in and concepts of divinity and dreams
and miracles they're interested in
seeing what is really out there and
painters we're scientists at the time
and so you have a number of painters in
the Renaissance who developed the idea
of perspective and you have to project
this real world in 3d onto a 2d canvas
and and so that made people their lives
of all the ins and outs of image
formation and it allowed them people to
start thinking about how can you invert
that process you know how can you go
from an image back out to the world that
generated it and that's exactly what the
vision is all about and so at the
beginning of in 1900 there was a
practical problem which was
photogrammetry how do you reconstruct
terrain from pictures they can buy
airplanes and people did it by hand but
there was this concept that computation
is involved and you need to understand
geometry and so that's somehow the
beginning of computational vision is
opposed to computer vision so the
computation was done by a human but the
idea was you need to understand well the
geometry in the physics of image
formation in order to be able to invert
this process and people developed
equations to be able to invert
perspective whenever and I would start
understand when you can do it then in
the middle of the 1900 psychologists
started becoming really interested there
is also earlier work but you know
nineteen hundreds what are all the
processes that the brain might be using
and people realize that there were all
of these visual illusions which are not
mistakes of the visual system they're
just wrong assumptions if you will that
deficiency makes in inverting this this
map and physiology started in the 1960s
the physiology of the visual system and
people started measuring how neurons
code for different properties of the
image and so they realized that neurons
in the early visual system code for very
simple properties like edges and
textures and the stereoscopy disparity
and that gave a lot of inspiration to
computer vision people and so what is
computer vision is the idea that you can
build machines that can reproduce these
computational processes in order to
automatically extract meaning or
information about the world from images
and so that's where Roberts thesis comes
in so he had to invent the idea of say
extracting
Edge's because he realized that lines
the line drawing of a solid object is
very informative and then how do you use
that in order to reconstruct vision and
so that's how somehow computational or
computer vision started from a long
tradition of computational vision from
psychology from physiology and then the
the advent of computers and the hardware
with which we can capture cheaply
inexpensively images and so that's how
we all started about about 60 years ago
all right thank you so Larry these
groundbreaker is a really laid out the
foundation of computer vision from from
psychology and from findi algae but also
we can trace computer vision to a field
that at the time we called the picture
processor can you say a few word about
that
sure thing so in addition to being a
faculty member at the University of
Maryland I was also a graduate to the
north ear University of Maryland and in
1972 I joined the picture processing lab
at Maryland to work with my adviser
about him as well Rosen though who was
generally regarded as the founder of the
field of what we call today compute
computer vision right so Ezra wrote the
first text book in the mid-1960s he's
thought of the first journal and also
the first conference as well as
establishing I CCD in 1987 so Azure was
one of two or three real geniuses that I
knew in my lifetime having completed
both his PhD in mathematics and
rabbinical degree in his early 20s and
he had brought interests and not only
mathematics and computer science but
also psychology and neurophysiology so
the first day I show up at work to work
for this guy and he just gives me a
stack of papers and tells me to go away
and read them from top to bottom all
right and at the top of the stack was
one of the most famous papers in the
history of science it's a paper entitled
what the frog's eye tells the frog's
brain all right and this paper made what
at the time was a revolutionary claim
that vision systems were based on
extracting ecological features from what
the eye records so if you're a frog
right
these are moving blobs indicating prey
and predator okay rather than simply
mapping the input image somehow onto the
brain and there were all kinds of
theories about the early part of the
vision system doing some kind of
complicated local Fourier transform just
to get a copy of the image into the
brain that the brain could analyze
well further down the stack were papers
by Yubel and Wiesel they're famous
papers on single-cell recordings from
cells from cats and monkeys that Pietro
referred to a little bit earlier these
were the basis for the Nobel Prize and a
collection of older papers on neural
models and cellular automata like
Minsky's perceptron book which another
must read for every young student our
research at the time in the lab was
really more practical we were looking at
problems that were at the core of early
industrial vision systems this included
had a segment objects from images from
their background so to represent their
shapes of their textures and to identify
defects between observations and models
for the objects you were looking at and
infer and in fact the work done in our
lab form the basis for a generation of
industrial vision systems of course
compared to what we can do today with
computer vision it was all very
primitive as Pietro says nobody works on
edge detection anymore right a lot of
the problems we worked on a disappeared
we have lots of industrial collaborators
and that experience may be interested in
research that enabled applications of
that interest and lasted through my
entire career and as I said one of the
principal reasons that I left academia
and join Amazon is because there's
really no better company in the world
work on app real applications of
computer vision that are going to have
enormous impact from fashion to video
and music and on to physical stores like
Gerard's go I should say one of my
heroes early in my career as a professor
was Berthold horn from MIT horn was one
of the clearest and deepest thinkers in
the history of the field and his
research actually opened subfields a
video processing and physics based
vision so I'll close this segment by
saying that another paper that every
student should read is Horne's paper on
optical flow all right it reads like a
modern paper it's a beautiful work of
art and science it's interesting also
the one who Kearns
Crone's earliest papers was with Tom den
furred who went to Stanford who Pietro
actually Pietro didn't talk about Tom
Binford so I will tom was one of the
also the early pioneers in computer
vision working on some of the earliest
3d vision projects but the paper with
Horne was about edge detection right you
might want to read that be for this my
academic grandfather so is my advisor is
détendre and his advisor is Benford
right right good bloodlines
thank you well Ben friend also my
grandfather since my adviser was a
Romney mafia so we share a common
grandfather here yeah my my grandfather
of some obscure group theoretician at
Columbia who I don't know his name I
supported you know that by the way this
foundational and important research was
not just done in the US I mean there
were several others that have made a
valuable contribution for example in
Europe young cornering and only the
father has made a significant
contribution so ok so Larry you pointed
out that a computer vision is video Ford
I mean we have been working on this for
more than 50 years and we're not even
close to the capability of the human
visual system so why not what I guess
we're not as small as we thought we were
all right I mean this shouldn't really
be a surprise I mean after all a very
large part of our brains is devoted to
seeing right even though it seems to us
like some kind of effortless process and
January doesn't require any
concentration except for some visual
search problems but remember in the
early days of AI people thought vision
would be solved before complex games
like chess and go and we all know that
isn't the way it played out I mean
there's the famous summer vision project
at MIT you know I think Gerry Sussman
who was an undergraduate at the time was
given the sub task of working on color
constancy he was going to knock it off
in four weeks
alright you know the problem really
never got solved Sussman's a full
professor at MIT who never worked on
computer vision again right moved on to
fields where there were problems he can
solve so it's always been hard right
there's there's lots of reasons I think
that every student knows about the loss
of information and going from 2d to 3d
complex imaging conditions like
reflections transparency atmospherics
and you know large variability in the
appearance of everyday things I think
one of the really hard and outstanding
challenges to computer vision one of the
biggest challenges is to achieve
human-level vision is the interaction of
knowledge and common sense with computer
vision I work on this problem throughout
my career looking at various ways of
integrating different types of
probabilistic logics with vision for
even simple applications like activity
detection and sports video right there
we use rules of the game not always
follow to the letter at all by the
players to provide a set of external
constraints on how athletes interact
with each other in the field of the ball
and how the game is developed right and
so we built these soft logical models
for this knowledge that controlled their
ease vision modules to overcome
deficiencies in observation but I'm
learning how to integrate common sense
reasoning into deep learning systems a
major challenge and I think really
anybody knows how to do this yet it's a
really large outstanding problem it's a
very challenging area to work in but one
with just exceptional potential rewards
ok ok you want to add something to this
sure yes so I think a lot of you're
right on target and so what I can add is
also that we are always hungry right so
vision is this wonderful sensor which is
non-contact it's very rich and it allows
it's it's passive so we don't even need
to project out energy in order to to
sense the world and it allows us to
discover so much and you know what are
the limits to what can we find out about
the world we don't know there are so
many things that we want to know about
and so apart from this intrinsic
ambiguity of images but then there are
you know so many things that can look at
your face right now it's not that I see
the head of Larry Davis I see
Davis and I can I can guess how your
whole posture is if I only see your your
head and your shoulders I can imagine
your mmm imagine your emotions in this
moment we have this bond with this
connection and so there are so many
things we can do with vision and so we
will always be hungry and it's difficult
to see a point where we stop discovering
new things they can do with this
wonderful sensor thank you thank you all
right so let's switch topic a bit here
as you probably are aware I'm the
general chair of this year CBPR
conference Steve EPR started in 1983 was
just a few people and there has been
exponential growth year after year
because of the way the field has grown
so I want to talk a bit not about just
the application for computer vision that
exists today but what makes the field so
exciting so both of you you you actually
wrote paper that are gonna be presented
at this conference so let's start there
let's start with various earlier you
have a paper on fashion item retrieval
can you talk about this work and how you
are approaching the application of
computer vision for help in shopping for
clothes online sure thing
all right so the customer problem that
we're trying to address in this paper is
that a lot of times you see an item for
sale in the Amazon catalog but people
don't know how to wear it okay there's
nothing apply so much there were those
of us attending conferences in person we
all wear jeans and conference t-shirts
but for a lot of people shopping online
right they want to wear a certain style
they want to understand how things go
together alright so you see something
stylish what we'll go with so the idea
is to look at fashion compatibility
right this is based on an item's pattern
material texture shade color a whole set
of variables to show customers how to
wear an item and what to pair it with
but an important challenge is that four
different pairs of product types the
product dimensions that determine
stylistic compatibility will there so
technically what we do is we were in
style
stuffed subspaces to model these
pairwise product Hut compatibilities and
most important develop a scalable
approach to building outfits that can be
applied to a catalogue as vast as
Amazon's right that is the model is able
is actually able to produce in style
consistent embeddings that can be used
for retrieval so we can retrieve
compatible items rather than just being
able to rank pairs of items with respect
to compatibility and this is the trick
to having a scalable solution right so
when this technology is embedded in an
Amazon product customers will have more
confidence by knowing how to wear any
item they're interested in or what and
what else would go with it and given
what's occurring with the koban 19
pandemic this work might even be more
significant because customers might want
to do more of their shopping online all
right thank you
okay jewel you you wrote a paper on zero
short video classification it so can you
tell us more about how you took this
problem of expensive video data
annotation and proposed the radically
new approach using this zero shot
learning yeah so first of all this is
the work of of Biagio Bratley who is a
brilliant PhD student in germany who
spent a summer with us in 2019 and this
is the time to mention it so we have
this beautiful summer intern program at
Amazon we get amazing PhD students who
work with us it's a joy for us to be
able to to work with the students and
it's a moment where we can take
intellectual risks so we're not
developing a product we're just taking a
stab in the dark trying something
difficult and the students get a lot of
firsthand exposure to the tools we use
and also to the mentality of how you
develop a product in industry so they
get to to understand how companies
working and that's very useful it's an
eye opener for many students and make is
going back to the question so there is
this problem of zero shot learning so
what is it
we know that it's Biaggio is B are you
coming to Amazon afterwards
sooner so so what's the problem with
zero shot learning so we we know we want
to one of the things that our visual
system does effortlessly is categorizing
things so all of us can talk about dogs
we talk about trees and cell phones and
so on and and we cannot recognize a dog
even if it belongs to a breed we've
never seen before and so when a new
object comes along we have never at a
loss for what might it be or will very
rarely at the last we can tell which
category it is and that helps us a lot
because we know how to respond to that
object how to make use of it what the
properties might be now we know that one
of the places where computer vision and
machine learning in general have not
become as good as humans is the
efficiency of learning in order to train
a system that recognizes birds for
example we know that we need about a
thousand pictures for each species in
order to be able to train the system
that's very expensive and sometimes
simply we don't have enough pictures of
a certain species so the question is can
we do like the human visual system and
be prepared to recognize or learn a new
category from having seen similar
categories or related ones before and
therefore can we be ready to learn a new
one and so if you take a birder to Papua
New Guinea they've never been there you
show them three or four pictures of a
given bird a bird of paradise whatever
they learn it immediately while our
machines are much dumber than that
so what Biaggio was looking at is can we
prepare a machine to learn from video
actions and activities which are very
useful thing to recognize and can we do
so with zero prior training examples and
so of course I will not tell you how it
goes because you've got to read the
paper but that was a problem and there
is a very simple and elegant solution
that we used and it's way way better
than what was there before so that's
wonderful thank you thank you so so we
have looked at the history we have
looked at the couple we have
talked about a couple papers that are
appearing here let's look a little
further out and ask the question what do
you think that biggest opportunities for
computer vision are given as a progress
of the field and what we know today
Larry all right this is any question I
hate the most
right this is a hard question to answer
but I'd like to try and give an answer
that maybe you couldn't have given ten
years ago right so everybody's known
forever that if the computer vision
problem could be solved then it would
enable endless applications in many
areas in fact this is the main reason
that field receives substantial and
continuous funding in the United States
even though progress until recently was
let's say painfully slow all right with
some notable exceptions like 3d shape
recovery slam things of that sort right
so one area that I think is high
potential growth is content creation in
fact there's a very interesting workshop
on this topic at cvpr
and of course this is largely being
enabled by the remarkable recent
progress on Gann so this is an explosive
growth area that would have been hard to
predict ten years ago because you needed
a technological breakthrough another is
is sight and sound I think this is
really exciting all right the decades
researchers tried to get robots to see
but they never listen to anything they
didn't hear anything i cou sztyc scene
analysis is very challenging and it's
actually fun to argue about whether
vision or sound is harder right they're
both hard but for different reasons the
recent work we seen in the field on
sound solar separation is very
compelling in fact it's borderline
astounding and work like the work being
done in two robbers group at MIT on
sound addition should inspire more
students to work on these problems if
you want an historical reference there
was psychologist his name was Bregman
and he wrote an interesting book on
acoustic scene analysis in the 70s that
you can dig into and take a look at what
was known about the subject back then
but it's very hard alright
and then I win with a suggestion which
is probably wrong right a long shot
proposal and that's documents right I
don't just mean getting vision systems
be able to read and
organizers summarize 20 20 style
documents which is an important problem
but actually rethinking what documents
are in the context of computer vision
and modern AI by just changing the way
we communicate I think that computer
vision is gonna play a large role there
interesting that's thought-provoking and
that's different
absolutely Pedro you have other
perspective on this as well yeah yeah of
course it sounds to me it sounded like
Larry definitely hate the question he
loves it and and by the way if people
are interested in document there is a
wonderful team at Amazon Web Services
that has a system out called extract and
of course I'm not going to talk about
what they're going to do in the future
but the present is already quite
interesting yeah so just to mention
another couple of ideas so one that I'm
quite keen to to see develop is their
understanding of causality and we've
been now almost
poisoned or gotten addicted by the idea
of learning and with learning we learn
correlations between things and that's
really good for predicting but as we
develop machines that go out in the
world like autonomous driving cars and
robots that interact with people we need
to understand cause and effect
relationships because if you want to
affect the world you need to understand
what causes what and and that's very
primitive in computer vision in fact
most computer vision researchers don't
understand the difference between cause
and causality and correlation it so we
need to put in some effort there so that
we enable machines to understand cause
and effect and by the way humans are
also pretty bad at understanding cause
and effect so they would be to do better
than the average human at that then you
can think of machines that understand
cause and effect would be really useful
in science I think of many biology
experiments you could carry out and and
how much you could understand about the
world so this one a second one that
really fascinates me is is connecting or
developing machines that help us put
together knowledge
and so what they observe is that visual
knowledge but knowledge in general is
very distributed amongst humans so if
you think of a birder that goes out in a
little nice Birds of California but we
take them to Australia and they don't
know what they're looking at or a
radiologist may be really good with bone
cancer but you show them really redress
of liver and they're not super good they
have to ask their colleague to help them
out right so any community has a lot of
knowledge but the knowledge is
distributed amongst the people and it's
there in data mmm and machines can learn
from each one of the components of a
community and so I feel that we are
slowly flipping the tables on on the
problem of machine learning so it used
to be that the machine is sitting there
it's like a tool and we are like an
Oracle we gave a machine some knowledge
of machine has to learn it and now we
have more and more machines that face a
community where knowledge is distributed
and it's the machine has to figure out
who knows what and ask people the right
questions to be able to to instruct
itself and through Amazon Mechanical
Turk we have this developed disability
now - we have methods statistical
methods to understand who knows what and
which annotators are giving us the right
knowledge which was or not so we're
making progress there and some of my
students have been working with the
California Academy of Science to build
an app called eye naturalist which you
can use to recognize plants and animals
in fact I would encourage everyone to
them load it to their smart devices and
this app is so there is a system in a
server that is learning all the time
from what what labels people give to the
different animals and plants and there
are some people who are experts and the
machine knows what the experts and it
pays attention to what they say and and
it doesn't pay attention to people like
me who don't know anything and it trains
itself by by interacting with the
community so we're up now to 50 or
60,000 species of plants and animals
that the Machine has learned from people
and the goal is half a million so one
somewhat ambitious idea I have is that
maybe
our field can help humanity organize all
of its knowledge in a way that is very
active so that the machine knows who
knows what it knows how to put you in
touch with the expert it can answer many
questions by itself we can tell you
which data are relevant and which parts
of knowledge are ambiguous and need to
be understood better so that's another
place where I think the divisions in do
a lot with the search belong is called
visit pedia I mean there are many of
course other application of computer
vision that existed for a long time you
know cultural heritage preservation of
cultural Heritage's is one such example
well thank you both I mean that kind of
brings us to the end of this virtual
discussion I want to thank everyone for
tuning in in to this event and to the
two of you my co-panelists
professor Larry Davis professor Pietro
Perona
if you're interested to learn more about
Amazon computer vision initiative as
well as other AI ml work I strongly
encourage you to visit the website at
Amazon that science if you click on the
virtual sponsor page on the website it
will take you to Amazon that science and
we look forward to connecting with you
during and after this very unusual and
unique cvpr conference thank you
you